if you just search on truckers it'll
start to autofill for you for now you
know autofill is often
downgraded when it does things that the
powers that be don't want um but you'll
find either truckers for freedom
truckers for truckers for freedom 2022
truckers convoy
2022
and basically you've got uh an
incredible number i've seen i've seen a
number of estimates the most usual one
is you know 50 000 trucks maybe
spread across um
you know a long range across canada
i've seen so many different estimates
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna guess here
um uh
driving
slowly um because there's so many of
them and because it's january and canada
and because they are going through these
towns um so they're heading to ottawa
the the capital um and they say that
they will be there uh until
uh the insane canadian policies around
things like mandates and blocking people
from actually getting services unless
they comply with um
with these these ridiculous rules are
are taken down
uh are reversed and as they're going
through these towns and even not in
towns and again you know canada in
january it it ain't easy to be outside
but they've got you know there's just
people lining the roads cheering on the
truckers
while you're talking yeah um
so here you can see people are cheering
lining the roads they're
waving canadian flags and banners
and
what you may or may not be able to see
you'll see it upcoming here every
overpass is full of people cheering
the truckers
on
and you know in some sense they are
circumventing the system that controls
what we know about how other people feel
right so we've had these this looks like
it's not taken from within the convoy
because there's no big rigs in front of
this guy and he's going pretty fast
right so is he ahead of it as far as you
know i don't exactly know okay um so i
am going to i am going to post either
today or tomorrow on my substitute a
bunch of a bunch of these videos i think
that actually do you know from from
within or from the science from within
our overhead i've seen yeah um it's
extremely it's obviously hard to capture
a convoy this big you could do it from
space maybe
yeah oh that man that would be great
yeah i want to show just a few
screenshots here zach from from tweets
here we have justin trudeau the prime
minister of canada back on march 31 2020
remember march 31st 2020 things things
were things were getting pretty pretty
ugly yeah
it was this is one of these lines i
don't i have not gotten why people keep
invoking yet because it was patently
untrue at the time like this is one of
the things that was just patently untrue
at the time but two weeks to flatten the
curve somehow a lot of people believed
that and um it never looked like that
from where we're sitting but okay this
is back around that era
he says then
while many of us are working from home
there are others who aren't able to do
that like the truck drivers who are
working day and night to make sure
ourselves are stocked so when you can
please hashtag thank a trucker for
everything they're doing and help them
however you can
we will see shortly how trudeau has
changed his position um here we have
from you know right now this is a nun um
holding a sign that says god bless you
convoy truckers free forever
love this
uh here we have a little bit small again
um a um
an invitation for january 29th 2022
that's sunday
um nationwide business reopening no more
mandates and solidarity with the
truckers convoy to ottawa on january
29th 2022 businesses canada-wide will be
opening their doors at full capacity and
abandoning all restrictions no masks no
vaccine passports no capacity limit and
it should not require to be said but
this is not about being anti-vaccine
this is about being anti-vaccine
mandate anti-vaccine passports needing
vaccines to get into services like
restaurants and and theaters
uh next one and this is very um
very much a match for something you
already said brett but remember they
have made the decision to dismiss child
abuse suicides overdoses domestic
violence seniors dying alone destroyed
economy businesses families friendships
and risk our health for a product that
doesn't work
all to implement a passport
trucker's convoy 2022
and here we have
not my prime minister
but oops sorry
justin trudeau oh i managed to
take the i think this is from
two days ago now i think this is from
january 26th
um last night i learned that i have been
exposed to covet 19. my rapid test
result was negative i am following
ottawa health rules and isolating for
five days i feel fine we'll be working
from home stay safe everyone and please
get vaccinated
he's so patently hiding
right and he's so patently hiding from
what he knows in the middle of his
self-imposed quarantine he's a
he's a world leader who got exposed of
course he just got exposed of course he
got exposed to omar kron um during the
you know while omicron is circulating he
is hiding
at the height of the trucker convoy's
power and reach and pretending that
that's not what he's doing pretending
this is about public health if he had
been anything like a leader to this
point you would have to wonder
thank you but um
i don't think we do he's a duplicitous
ken doll and
the fact is this is an obvious ploy and
what's more i can tell you
he actually does come down
uh with covid i assure you he will have
the highest quality early treatments
because of course you know why wouldn't
he
maybe for all we know he's on um right
and for those of you
for those of you who may be listening
and thinking what you're still claiming
that these early treatments work well
yes a we've experienced it b we've had
many friends who we have connected with
early treatments at the point they have
become sick and not a one of them has
had it fail um so yes they work but also
um
as you will find in many places
increasingly you will see it with video
tess lori caught andrew hill
admitting that the reason that his
meta-analysis says ivermectin's utility
is questionable is that he was pressured
to say that right so
um anyway it's not in doubt
[Music]
you